julio de 1997
un domingo por la tarde llegué aquí
grama aquí en el centro de encuentros
cerca de medellín invitada a un
seminario para hablar del futuro de
colombia
al llegar se ubicaría como muchos
guardias armados pero en esa época no
era raro porque colombia estaba pasando
por una de las épocas más complicadas de
la historia todos los días vivíamos en
alerta continua entre los guerrilleros o
narcotraficantes en la institucionalidad
presidencial cuestionada la corrupción
y eso sumado a los problemas de siempre
no la desigualdad
las otras violencias la pérdida de
biodiversidad de manera que en el 97
colombia concentraba todos los problemas
juntos y exacerbados
ese domingo yo llegué aquí la ma
no me entregaron agenda ni lista de
asistentes estoy yo salí a ver quién me
encontraba y me encontré con alguien me
puse a conversar a tomar un tinto pues a
tardear un domingo en rionegro
en el curso de la conversación sin
embargo empecé a darme cuenta de que yo
no conocía a este señor con la que
estaba hablando pero que sí lo reconocía
y lo reconocía porque lo había visto en
los carteles de se busca por la cantidad
de causas criminales atroces que tenía a
su cargo
ustedes no se imaginan el susto que
estoy haciendo acá
pero ya más a esta gente como se le
ocurre invitarlo a uno sin avisar
ese fue para mí el comienzo de destino
colombia
un ejercicio de planeación por
escenarios donde 43 colombianos
trabajamos durante varias semanas con la
dirección de anncaje en un experto
mundial en temas de negociaciones en
conflictos
para construir cuatro escenarios
factibles de lo que nosotros pensábamos
que podía hacer colombia en los
siguientes 15 años
leer esos escenarios hoy es
impresionante porque fuimos capaces de
predecir de forma muy acertada lo que
terminó pasando en colombia
en esos siguientes años que en el 97 uno
pensaba que sí pero que no se podía y
terminó pasando todo lo que se predijo
en esos escenarios esa capacidad de
predicción es tan acertada porque los
escenarios son el resultado del trabajo
de 43 personas completamente diferentes
cada uno de nosotros con su lente
diferente
ese es el poder de la diversidad
destino colombia a mí me marcó
profundamente y me marcó de muchas
maneras pero sobre todo por la
posibilidad de vivir el proceso de
encontrar un punto en común a pesar de
todas las diferencias
estábamos en desacuerdo el 99.9 las
cosas ese pequeñito porcentaje que quedó
nos permitió trabajar juntos
en destino colombia había enemigos
enemigos mortales enemigos de la guerra
y muchos no nos conocíamos
muchos no nos queríamos ni siquiera
conocer en realidad
y no se trataba que nos pusiéramos de
acuerdo
ni tampoco se trataba que dijéramos lo
que quería que pasara
solamente que lográramos construir entre
todos lo que nos imaginábamos que sería
colombia en los siguientes 15 años y
logramos en ese ejercicio hacer algo
mucho mejor que lo que cada uno de
nosotros habría podido lograr hacer surf
22 años después 2019 vivimos hoy en la
sociedad más interconectada de la
historia
sin embargo vivimos cada vez más
polarizados
ante la avalancha información las redes
sociales las noticias falsas las
campañas de miedo y de odio ya nadie
sabe a quién creerle terminamos como
guardados entre una burbuja
un filtro que los científicos y
académicos que están estudiando este
problema llaman de polarización afectiva
y es el hecho que las personas cada vez
más estamos menos dispuestos a
asociarnos oa socializar con personas
que consideramos que son diferentes o
que pertenecen a grupos diferentes
y eso está pasando en colombia y está
pasando en el mundo entero no es sino
mirar los resultados de las elecciones
en gran bretaña con el break situ en
eeuu las elecciones presidenciales o en
tantos países que vemos estos resultados
electorales que muestran países
completamente polarizados
y no se trata solamente de los
resultados públicos electorales los
grandes temas de las naciones es que esa
polarización nos está afectando también
en el cotidiano porque cada vez es más
difícil incluso con la familia con los
amigos tener conversaciones
la
forma de construir conversaciones
no siempre es fácil
y no es fácil porque se trata de un
proceso emocional no es un proceso
racional
y no hay un camino único hay muchos
caminos para encontrar la solución
la pregunta a la que nos enfrentamos hoy
es
en el mundo más entero e interconectado
donde a la vez estamos cada vez más
distantes
qué tenemos que hacer para trabajar
juntos
siete años atrás con unos amigos creamos
sistema de una organización para
solucionar los problemas causados por la
forma como funciona la economía
sistema de trabajo de una forma muy poco
convencional pero a partir de un
principio relativamente simple invitamos
a
colaborar a pares improbables
no se trata de poner una agenda no se
trata de lograr un consenso solamente de
estar juntos y trabajar personas que de
otra forma difícilmente se habían
conocido en temas de solución de
problemas que no son comunes a todos
y de estos encuentros resultan cosas
extraordinarias como lo que está pasando
en la ciudad de santiago de chile
las ciudades son bueno primero el lugar
donde vivimos la mayor número de
personas del mundo pero amazon los
sitios donde se están concentrando la
mayoría de los problemas de la humanidad
como el coll como colombia en el 97 en
las ciudades se concentran todos los
objetivos de desarrollo sostenible de
las naciones unidas en santiago una
alianza llamada santiago + b que
representa mucho de la diversidad de la
ciudad hay empresarios empresarios ve
que todas las cosas están reinventando
la forma de hacer empresa hay amas de
casa hay autoridades hay artistas que se
han unido para cambiar la forma como los
ciudadanos se relacionan con la ciudad
en esa alianza decidieron hacer una
invitación a los ciudadanos a usar su
poder
para cambiar de ser usuarios que se
quejan a ser agentes de transformación y
de cambio de los problemas de su
comunidad
lanzaron un concurso donde cientos de
personas ofrecieron frases buenas para
ser convocatoria 20 artistas
entusiasmaron y hoy esas frases con esas
obras de arte son murales en edificios
gigantescos están en los buses
eléctricos de santiago en los puntos de
bus
hasta en la tarjeta del metro y pasan
cosas una que a mí me fascinó en un
barrio los vecinos decidieron que lo que
querían era poner el arte en el suelo y
entre todos pintaron y construyeron un
camino de seguridad para que los niños
pudieran ir a la escuela
como les decía trabajar juntos con
personas diversas y en situaciones de
conflicto pues no es fácil y no es fácil
porque es un problema emocional un
desafío que no es racional solamente y
las personas somos todos diferentes y
somos diferentes porque tenemos dolores
diferentes alegrías diferentes hemos
tenido vidas diferentes duelos distintos
cada uno de nosotros es único
y además tener diferencias sobre asuntos
fundamentales es un hecho de la vida
el problema es que nos da miedo estar
juntos y no nos da miedo estar juntos y
queremos huir cuando yo llegué a esto y
no colombia lo primero que quería era
salir corriendo y yo estoy segura que
los guerrilleros que me vieron a mí como
una típica señora del norte de bogotá
querían salir corriendo pues mucho más
rápido que yo
también queremos controlar queremos
decimos bueno es que yo sí sé lo que hay
que hacer
es que el problema son nosotros es que
si los otros cambiarán ahí todo se
arreglaría pero la verdad es que el
problema somos todos cuando no podemos
controlar uno y lo otro que tratamos de
hacer es
hacernos los locos
hacer como que no nos importa deje así
como decimos acá en colombia
lo que yo aprendí en destino colombia es
que es posible trabajar con personas con
las que no estamos de acuerdo que no nos
gustan y que ni siquiera les podemos
tener confianza
destino colombia y santiago más bien nos
muestran la importancia de encontrar un
punto en común que nos permita trabajar
juntos por encima de las diferencias
yo quiero aquí hoy hacer dos reflexiones
la primera es que estamos juntos
vivimos en el mismo planeta y este es un
solo barco
la segunda es que todos somos el
problema
todos somos los otros de alguien
pero como somos el problema precisamente
por esa razón es que podemos ser los
cocreadores de la solución
y para terminar quiero dejarles una
invitación
a gozar nos el privilegio
de trabajar juntos por encima de la
necesidad de estar de acuerdo muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]